It's a staggeringly close call...
…when charging e-bikes suddenly catch fire nearly engulfing a young child in its fury.
It's like a blowtorch, where fire everywhere.
As so-called micromobility devices, like e-scooters and e-bikes...
…have exploded in popularity nationwide,...
...so have the number of injuries involving them.
And officials say, problems have been flaring up more...
…during the charging of the highly flammable lithium-ion batteries.
It looks like a really powerful firework.
Mauricio Orosco says all it took was a single faulty battery...
...to demolish his bike shop.
All the cells from the battery went everywhere in the shop,...
...so the explosion was really really hard.
An e-bike battery was blamed for this blaze, too.
Forcing daring rope rescues from a 20th story window.
Here in New York, the increase in incidents is especially pronounced,...
...as commuters and food delivery workers alike, lean on the devices...
...to help crisscross the busy city streets.
So far this year, lithium-ion batteries have sparked...
…nearly 200 fires in New York City,...
…injuring more people than the last three years combined.
Does that make you nervous at all?
Yeah, sure, of course.
Of course the battery, I have to pay attention with the battery.
And while officials consider policies regulating refurbished batteries,...
…many acknowledge e-bikes are here to stay.
Reminding riders never charge the battery unattended or overnight.
If the battery appears damaged, stop using it.
And most importantly, only use the charging equipment made for your device.
As fire officials try to steer the statistics in a safer direction.
Emilie Ikeda, NBC News New York.